こんにちは。はじめしゃちょーです。
俺はぁーッ！
俺は今まで段ボールを、
引っ越してから
ずぅーっとためてきた。
部屋が汚い汚いと言われたんですけども、
俺は頑張ってなぁ?!
ここにある段ボール全部集めたわけよ。
こんなにでかいのとかもありますからね。
なぜ?!
こんなにたくさんの段ボールを集めたかと言うとォ！
ある一つの
目標を目指していたのさ。
そう。
俺はこの段ボールたちを全部使って
（手を叩く音）
またこれはギネスだ。
この部屋ですね。
この部屋に――
ダンジョン、迷路を造ります。
大変だよ？
大変なのは分かっているけど――
やっぱ、ダンジョン職人としてそこは譲れない。
ダンジョン職人はじめーんは
部屋に迷路を造ることを誓う。
では行こう！！
何時間かかるんだろうなぁ？！（ヤケクソ）
（段ボールを置く音）
え？めんどくさ～
いや、めんどくさいのは分かっているけれども――
一人やりきることに意味がある
（テープを切る音）
（段ボールを解体するはじめの悲鳴）
よっしゃぁ！　きたきたきたっ
（はじめのくしゃみ）
（はじめの悲鳴）
まって待って、頑張ってがんば――
（はじめの嘆き）
ヤバイ、ヤバイヤバイ☆？◆▽
固まるはじめ
ちょっと一人じゃ無理だと思ったんで、
助っ人を呼んできました。
（謎のタイ語？）
とりあえず造ろう！
（手を鳴らす音）
造ることに意味がある！
（秘技：はじめゴットブレス）
（相手をのけぞらせる効果あり）
（ゴットブレス2発めェ！）
（とどめだァ！）
あ、痛いッ
間違えっちゃった（笑）
（秘技：はじめズ狂乱の歌）
あ、ねえ聞いて？
aikoさんへの愛を語るはじめ氏
（はじめのあくび）
はい。
と言うわけで、大分来たんですけれど、ほぼ終盤です。
乱暴しないでぇ
はいっ。
と言うわけで、こんな感じでございまーす
まじで多分、部屋のあらゆるところを全部迷路にしたので――
割とマジな迷宮になっております
はい。と言うわけでですね、
今からオイラのちょっと後輩が俺ン家に来るんですけども、
部屋で段ボールで造った迷路をちょっと実験的に――
使わせてみます。
僕がちょっとゴールに隠れているんで――
この迷路はちゃんと迷路として機能しているのかっていうのを――
ちょっと実際に、確かめてみようと思います
では行こう（心なし小声）
（はじめの笑い声）
ようこそ、はじめの迷路へーーーー！！
「さあ、この迷路をーー見事クリアし、
私を探してみるのだーー」
（勝ち誇ったはじめの笑い声）